nous sommes en guerre ce sont les mots
d' emmanuel macron pris hier soir lors
d'une allocution très attendue le chef
de l'état a pris la parole pour de
nouveaux alerter les français sur les
dangers du coronavirus il a annoncé un
arsenal de mesures d'une radicalité
inédite afin de lutter contre la
pandémie du colis de 19 des mesures qui
à son tour le ministre de l'intérieur a
détaillé un peu plus tard dans la soirée
parmi elles la restriction de tous les
déplacements en france à partir de midi
siège hardy dans mon lit nous sommes en
guerre
à six reprises le chef de l'état a
utilisé la même expression une
allocution de 22 minutes la deuxième en
cinq jours un ton martial qui vise a
sonné la mobilisation générale contre un
ennemi invisible et insaisissable selon
le président de la république nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
j'ai décidé que le second tour des
élections municipales serait reporté les
frontières à l'entrée de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen
seront fermés j'ai décidé que toutes les
réformes en cours seraient suspendus à
commencer par la réforme des retraites
je sais mes chers compatriotes pouvoir
compter sur vous dans la foulée de
l'allocution présidentielle christophe
castaner s'est chargé de justifier les
mesures annoncées par emmanuel macron
sur un ton plus ferme que celui du
président de la république le ministre
de l'intérieur a détaillé les nouvelles
mesures de confinement sur les modèles
espagnol et italien pour une durée de
quinze jours qui pourrait être prolongé
des mesures de restriction ferme des
déplacements ont été prises le mot
d'ordre est clair
restez chez vous il s'agit de mesures de
confinement sur le modèle de ce que nos
voisins espagnols ou italiens ont mis en
place ce que le président de la
république a décrit ce sont les mesures
les plus restrictives aujourd'hui en
vigueur en europe
nous menons un combat nous le ferons
respecter un dispositif de contrôle sera
mise en place est assurée par cent mille
forces de l'ordre avec des points fixes
ou mobiles sur les grands axes et les
routes secondaires toute personne
circulant devra porter une attestation
téléchargeable sur le site du ministère
de l'intérieur pour justifier sur
l'honneur le motif de son déplacement en
cas d'absence de raisons sérieuses la
violation de ces règles sera puni d'une
amende
actuellement de 38 euros elle sera
portée par décret à 135 euros